so bekommen warum fragen lotto ich ziehe
eine frage aus außerdem ist es so
tatsächlich wir haben uns überlegt wie
möglich ärgern können das in die roten
fragen oder wie wir ganz lieb und nett
zu dir sind es in die grünen fragen du
kannst selber wählen bitte schön
wirklich ich merke ich ein idiot wenn
ist eine gute frage würde ja aber ich
wäre was genau ich erwähnen wären alle
meine gäste idioten sind wir alle gut
meistens ziehen die klage weil die
wissen wollen ich mal so kann es auch
selber aufmachen aber ich bin geübt die
wollen wissen was man schlechtes
übersehen welche normalerweise macht das
der gast als besser wenn du das machst
also muss es lauern rough 30 mehr
musiker als rapper machst du jetzt auch
einen auf cool hatte sich jemand
wirklich geschrieben
der erklärte er das macht das auf große
musiker wird er nicht sagen
doch melodischer und da wird mir
gesungen wird nicht sagen es heißt ja
auch werden also pop und rap also ich
würde gerne noch quorum auch ich würde
gerne platin verkaufen ein mercedes benz
das schneiden und eine maske tragen
damit ich in ruhe in meinem bezirk
umgehen kann also würde ich gerne aber
wie gesagt also frage bisschen komisch
wenn wie gesagt für mich war froh jetzt
nicht der der so auf musiker machte sehr
sollen max herre wenn mir sagen würde
machst du jetzt auf max er überdies ein
jahr auf jeden fall okay heute gut also
würdest du nicht als den du würdest
nicht sagen dass du mit deinem deiner
musik
so in diese richtung vorgeben gar nicht
also ich bin älter ist aber es ist
musikalisch also ich habe immer schon
musikalisch erklärten gemacht wenngleich
immer glaube sogar und ich bin sicher
ich weiß nicht ich bin sicher dass crow
auch meine musik kannte und ihm das
bestimmt auch gefallen hat vielleicht
weil das musikalisch war oder so ich
weiß nicht aber also graumarkt seien auf
rang 83 punkten auf gar keinen fall kann
man nicht sagen kann man wirklich nicht
vergleichen
du willst du findest dich also kanal nee
also wie gesagt es wäre ein cooler
vergleich also das wäre an sich wie
gesagt der erfolgreichste rapper zu zeit
doch gut wenn man wenn man einen mit dem
vergleich noch nicht machst du einen
drauf of murder a oder b benji oder ob
man ihn wohl du kannst du ja klar aber
auch bei mir das war sehr lustig immer
mehr gesagt hast du endlich gemerkt dass
du nicht retten kann habe ich muss
ehrlich sagen ich habe wirklich gemerkt
dass ich halt rappen kann jeder und es
gibt viele leute die besser mit 90 und
meinen gesang style da habe ich auf
jeden fall quasi etwas eigenes sozusagen
also der zwischen bisschen angreifen
dargestellt aber im endeffekt hatten gar
nicht so unrecht
ok also ich kann auf jeden fall retten
was ich besser kann ist das ganze
vermischen die gesangs fuchs die liegen
noch mehr gut sehr gut wird das
vielleicht noch musikalisch in zukunft
ich habe meine politischen freunde erst
zahlen wenn sie etwas kommen wir so
bisschen so lustiges macht es so dass
schießt es ab mit dem feind kraft
rennrad kamera folgt ist so eine lebende
identitätskrise aber es ist bestimmt
mädchen geschrieben hat man ja noch mehr
identitäten dabei ja ja ja das war
wirklich wie gesagt ja bin ich ja ein
bisschen 'schon also hat gar nicht so
unrecht wie gesagt das war mein erster
ecke
eine kamera ist so leider oder gott sei
dank ich was nicht wissen ja alle recht
gut damit aber eine grüne frage ist noch
eine grüne bestimmt nur dass meine
schuhe gut sind wenn sie von nike sind
okay du sprichst französisch italienisch
und deutsch bist du ein sprachgenie also
es gibt leute zum beispiel meinen co
produzent kanye wir spricht
ich weiß nicht also noch mal mehr
sprachen endlich normal perfekter ich
spreche deutsch und französisch perfekt
italienisch spreche ich nicht zumute
französisch oder deutsch also und
englisch spreche ich sehr sehr sehr sehr
schlecht also bin ich gern sprachgenie
aber danke fürs kompliment danke für die
frage gern geschehen
versuche gestellt das ist teamarbeit
also meistens oft ist teamarbeit
stichwaffen dein freund
wieso respektieren sich so viele
kollegen kollegen wie sowie respektieren
sich so viele kollegen also wenn sie
mich respektieren also wie gesagt ich
hab keinen beef mit man kann ja noch
kommen kann ja mit dir wo mit zwei
kollegen da ist das schlecht
ja auf jeden fall ich weiß nicht also
wie gesagt ich respektiere sie und ich
ruf respekt in den wald um respekt kommt
zurück
also wie man in den wald hineinruft so
schallt es heraus
die alten guten alten weisheiten die
letzte grüne noch mehr musst du das
machen was ist auf dreh wird gemacht
wird aber ich habe auch schon mal ich
habe sogar mal ein lehrvideo darüber
gedreht wie manchmal derweil läuft weil
björn läuft definitiv ruhig ließ dass
wir züge verkehrt alles verkehrt liegen
du kannst ja fast alles verkehrt liegen
nein wirklich verkehrt wo hast du das
gelernt also verkehrt lesen gerne ein
bisschen kind bin will ich bitten mit
verkehrten menschen aufgebracht
gewachsen
ich kann fast alles aber wie gesagt wenn
es um also ich weiß nicht so männlich
instrumente in der schule von meinen
eltern von von mir selbst danke auf
jeden fall für die für diese frage wer
auch immer sie gestellt die an die roten
waren dankeschön
sie ist auf die grüne ist schwerer zu
antworten
es ist immer so und ich danke vielmals
ich danke dir danke euch